hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
benefits of automation in medical
laboratories i am jennifer woods of lab
roots and i will be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by abbott diagnostics
to learn more visit abbott.com now let's
get started
before we begin i would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speakers ann milne
biochemistry laboratory manager at
aberdeen royal infirmary
and paul drew senior chief biomedical
scientist
and hematology laboratory manager at
aberdeen royal infirmary for a complete
biography on our speakers please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen
ann and paul you may now begin your
presentation
thank you thank you jennifer for that
introduction
so today we're going to speak about the
benefits of automation in
medical laboratories as introduced my
name is paul drew and i'm the hematology
laboratory manager
and i'm anne milne i'm the laboratory
manager in clinical biochemistry at
aberdeen royal infirmary
to set the scene this we thought we'd
start off by letting you know where we
are
so here's a map of the uk showing where
scotland is
aberdeen is located up on the northeast
coast in the grampian region
the grampian region is the largest area
in scotland
um in region in scotland the area of the
region is
320 square miles which translates into
180 000 square kilometers
the region aberdeen is known as the
granite city and has been known as the
oil capital of virus
the region has a population of
approximately six hundred thousand
people
and observed by nhs grampian
if we just zoom in a little closer
on the region to give you an idea of the
geography you can see here in this slide
arbiting royal infirmary
located on the right hand side of the
picture and georgetown's hospital
located up in the northwest of the
region
the grampian nhs region consists of
those two hospitals but also has around
92 gp practices as well as outpatient
clinics dotted throughout the area
to give you an idea of the geography and
the distances involved here the distance
between
aberdeen and elgin is approximately 66
miles
which is about 106 kilometers that maybe
doesn't seem very far
in distance terms but when you couple
that with sometimes
inclement weather conditions that we see
in scotland
the logistics of traveling around the
area can be quite challenging
so gp samples in the region who are
sending samples to aubergine royal and
friendly on a daily basis
face this challenge we meet this by
having a courier service that collects
blood samples from all of its 92 gp
practices in the region
at the end of the gp's working day and
they transferred to arboretum royal
infirmary
which means that our departments with
hematology and clinical biochemistry are
receiving
the bulk of our workload at the end of
the working day
our core working hours between 5 p.m and
8 p.m
which does give its own challenges
so if we look at nhs grampian a bit more
detail starting with aberdeen royal
infirmary
the hospital was first established in
1739
and then moved to its current site in
1936 it was officially opened by the
duke and duchess of york at the time we
then joined the nhs in 1948
so since then until now there's been a
number of extensions new builds etc
added to their hospital site
which now seizes in 125 acre site
we're now a thousand bed teaching
hospital and we provide all the major
services including hemophilia center
oncology burns and dna and we're best
major trauma center
and been the first one to open in
scotland in 2018.
also on site we have a children's
hospital a pediatric hospital a maturity
hospital a neonatal unit
and also also a hospital for mental
health
we're covering a population of about six
hundred thousand
there's also an extensive laboratory
directorate within aberdeen royal and
primary and this consists of
microbiology virology immunology
genetics pathology as well as hematology
and biochemistry
the hospital at dr grayson elgin is a
much smaller hospital
and has 190 beds services covered
include
orthopedics maternity unit and accident
and emergency
in general surgery we have a dedicated
satellite laboratory in elgin staffed by
their own staff
we don't transfer staff between aberdeen
and elgin
so that they have their own dedicated
satellite laboratory there
and they deliver basic hematology and
basic biochemistry
and on the under the current climate
also covered testing now of course
and about to do the food testing as we
move into that season
any more any further complicated assays
would come down to hematology and
biochemistry into updating royal
infirmary
if we now look at the hematology in
biochemistry departments and we'll look
at these separately
in that they are autonomous departments
we reside in a building that was
initially erected in the early 1970s
so unfortunately it's not particularly
conducive to
a combined blood sciences so we have we
are on separate floors within this
building
so looking at hematology we have around
40 full-time staff
and that's made up of a biomedical
scientist
one clinical scientist biomedical
support workers
and a couple of consultants as well we
also have a number of part-time staff
that predominantly cover that busy back
shift period that i spoke about between
5 pm
and 8 pm when all the gp samples are
arriving
we offer a full 24 hour shift system so
that's a loan working from 10 pm
to 9 am on average we analyze about 2
and a half 000 full blood cancer day
eight hundred tematinics and 350
clotting screens in inrs
we also provide a full specialist
coagulation repertoire as well
added to this we also have a busy
hemolytic psychochemistry
and flow cytometry section our film
review rate
was sitting at about four percent but
since we've moved on to new analyzers
just recently
i would say that's probably more than
the region of six to seven percent as we
get accustomed to the analyzers
but we aim to get that film review rate
back down again
so a little bit about biochemistry
similar to
paul's description of hematology we also
work a 24-hour shift system where we
have a wound working
biomedical scientists working overnight
between 10 pm and 7 am
we have around 51 staff so we are
slightly
better stuff than hematology but we have
a combination
of staff from chemical pathologists
clinical scientists
biomedical scientists bi-mental support
workers
and associate practitioners you can see
from that slide there the kind of
services that we offer
so as well as routine chemistry and
immunology services
we also have some specialist chemists
chemistry
and protein section stuff as well as
toxicology
you can see our workload starts there as
well so on average we're looking at
around 3500 uni samples
a thousand glucoses 450 hbocs
and 1200 tsh daily so it is a very busy
department
a little bit about our health care
healthcare environment
now as we are in the northeast of
scotland this is quite an affluent area
but we do have a diverse population
quite aging
anyone who's familiar with the scottish
population will know that we're not
really
all that keen on the fitness side of
things and are more of an obese
population
we do like the food and the fine things
in life and we like a little drum of
whiskey every now and again
this has resulted in a number of
diseases that cause issues in our area
heart disease dementia cerebral cerebral
vascular disease
lower respiratory disease and diabetes
are very common
in our region and those are the
healthcare challenges that
we've got
so what are the challenges that we
actually face in hematology and
biochemistry
and i'm sure these challenges are very
familiar to all of you are actually
tuning into this and that's of staff
financial resources
and time and although we'll take these
separate they're all very much
interrelated as well
if we start off looking at staff we are
looking we have a very dedicated and
loyal workforce within abbey and royal
infirmary
the major turnover of staff is usually
down to retirement
and this creates its own challenges of
course and we're losing an awful lot of
experience and expertise
we are lucky that we have a university
on the doorstep that provides a
biomedical science degree course
but of course so recruitment isn't an
issue as such that we are recruiting
trainee medical scientists so we're
never been able to replace that
experience and expertise that we're
losing
although we're extremely grateful for
the trainees that are coming out of the
biomedical science degree course
if we look at the finances yeah and as a
laboratory manager i'm bound to say that
yes i don't have enough money
in my budget we all should say that
but year on year we've actually had
efficiency savings targets to meet
so they are placed on our budget and we
have to try and meet those
efficiency savings this is extremely
challenging as you can imagine
particularly when workload demands are
increasing
the whole time and also this is where it
interrelates with staff of course
in that we had an exercise several years
back where we had to look at our
workforce
and this came under the banner of safe
affordable workforce
so we went to look at a workflow force
and see where we could make
some financial savings because as we all
know staffing
is the main cost in our budgets so again
this is where we become quite lean when
it comes to staff and personnel
and of course we're all involved with
silo budgets so although we might be
able to make a saving
in one particular area it's extremely
difficult to say well look we need to
get money back into our budget because
we've saved money in
orthopedics or in reno etc that doesn't
often happen certainly not in the nhs
here in scotland
and then we'll look at time there's so
many conflicting demands
on our time these days so yes we're
having to to train
all the trainees that are coming out of
university to get give them that
experience and expertise
but we're also going to provide that
essential service to our users as well
of course and meet their demands meet
the turnaround times that we're expected
to deliver
on top of that we're all having to look
at our own competencies and keep
ourselves up to speed
and also we have to make sure that our
quality management system is in place
making sure we're appeasing our external
creditors that
come in and have a look around our
departments so of course we are all
having to do
more with less
this kind of just gives you an example i
particularly chose this like so it shows
hemotunics and coagulation samples
so these are samples that are actually
needing sample preparation
so they need to be spun offline they
need to be decapped
they need to be recapped and you can see
from here year on year increases
i did leave the coagulation one in here
because it does buck the trend there is
a decrease there
but that of course aligns with the point
of care analyzers that primary care
started using
for doing the inr testing so you can see
there is a slight drop there
but still a lot of sample preparation
that is required from the staff
if we look just purely at the hematitis
you can see in in 15 years
our samples have risen dramatically so
if we look at ferritins as a 78
increase in workload over that period of
time if we look at b12 and folate
we're actually looking at an 80 increase
over that period of time
i would love to say that my budget has
increased by 80 over that period of time
but unfortunately no such luck
and again full blood counts are our
mainstay in haematology our full blood
cat
samples in 10 years has risen by 18
so again typical year-on-year increases
on our workload
extra demands on the staff extra demands
on the finances
so how can we actually what can we do to
actually try and
make it easier on ourselves here
and just to continue on from what paul
has highlighted there
these are the workload figures for using
these in lfts in clinical biochemistry
in aberdeen
from the last 10 years and you can see a
similar workload increase
reflected in our department as as well
so let's just reflect on all of that as
we've described we have a large number
of number of samples coming into our
departments on a daily basis during a
busy short period
of the day where our queer workforce is
going home
if you think about what has to happen to
every sample and i'm shooting your labs
it's exactly the same when a sample
arrives in the department it has to go
under the pre-analytical checks
so we're then looking at has the sample
being labeled appropriately
are the patient demographics for that
sample correct
is it in the right tube type is it the
right shape for the assets that are
requested on
the sample and once having established
all that information is correct we then
have to order it into our
laboratory information management system
before we can then even proceed towards
thinking about analyzing the samples
in clinical biochemistry and sharing the
same in every
clinical biochemistry department gps
tend to
think about what they're asking and ask
for more more essays on one sample
than necessarily on an analyzer so
samples need to get moved from one
analyzer to another depending on what
tests are requested
and so you have to think about that when
you're getting your sample ready for an
analysis to make sure it goes to the
correct platform
samples then obviously once they're
typed into the information system
in biochemistry we need to centrifuge
samples
a sample before presenting it to the
instrument and then once the analysis is
complete we're doing that process in
reverse where the samples are taken off
of the instrument
recapped and filed filed in a system
where you can re
you can refine the sample if you need to
if you think about all of the manual
steps that are involved there or the
touch time on the samples
there's quite a lot of few health and
safety concerns too where
staff are taking tops of potentially
higher risk cycles and causing
aerosols to be created and exposure to
high risks
obviously using the automation makes all
of this so much easier
makes the work management of that work
so much easier and as well as the health
and safety concerns
streamlining the whole process and
allowing us to manage far more work than
we ever could
pre-automation steps in biochemistry as
well if we think of things
post-analytically
although we have a wide repertoire in
clinical biochemistry at aberdeen
we don't do every test and quite often
we receive requests for specialist tests
that need to get sent off to
a referral department so in
an average week that would be about 300
samples that we're sending away from
clinical biochemistry
prior to having automation those samples
had to be searched
by a member of staff before unquotes
were prepared for sending away with all
the necessary labeling
and of course there's a minefield of
error there where someone may be
choosing the wrong tube or
labels up another court wrongly um
leading to certain safety and quality
concerns round about that as well
the gp may often add on a test until
sample that's already in the lab as well
so to save the patient having to come
back into the gp surgery to be re-led
so if he phones up and adds on an
additional request then that scott
sample has to be found from
cold storage and put back onto
automation
and that's in addition to things like
reflex testing as we and reruns that we
do routinely
so as you can imagine all of that when
it's manually done
creates such a lot of work that can be
easily helped and
modified using automation to free up
staff to do more
skilled tasks recovery 19 pandemic has
introduced a whole new lot of challenges
for us as i'm sure it has for all of you
watching this presentation
we are although our sample numbers
didn't increase on on the grounds of the
kobe pandemic
we've had to think of loads of other
issues around keeping our staff safe and
trying to maintain social distance
so by using our automation sensibly
we're able to allow staff to
to move more freely in the department
further apart from each other
and that's helped us to keep them safe
so i quite enjoyed putting this slide
together because it's my own personal
timeline of automation from when i
started in the laboratory
and although making me feel absolutely
ancient when i look at it because it
spans across six decades
it is quite interesting so it shows how
automation has changed over time
and how we've benefited from that change
in automation
so if we start off in the late 60s and
70s
before i joined the lab i'd hasten to
add at this point of time
and what was required staff would have a
wander across to the
the board in their lab coats and a bit
of rubber tubing in their pocket
then they would then mouth pipette blood
which is quite incredible when you think
about it
and do the hemoglobin white cell count
red cell counts
using counting chambers as well they
even use
cocaine for counting platelets if that
all got too much then of course you
could lie down in the darkened room
which was required for doing our
microbial biological hematinic acids
so in 1979 when i did first join the the
lab
i would love to say i was five when i
joined that but i think
you might see through that one but when
i first joined the lab in 1979 with one
analyzer
which provided seven parameters so that
was a white count
a red count a hemoglobin and an mcv
and from that the mch the mch and
hematocrit were then calculated
if you wanted to have a platelet count
you needed a separate analyzer
and a sample dilution was then required
for actually doing your plant account so
again
more manual tech requirements but we
have moved to
radioisotopes for doing our hemotunics
now removing moving away from the
microbiological ones
and of course the results were printed
out onto a report card
you then had to take that report card
and manually transcribe those results
into the patient record we would then
photocopy that record
and send that result out to the board on
the photocopy
so yeah a lot of work was involved in
dealing with our sample workload
in the mid-80s we moved to another
analyzer which delivered 12 parameters
including our platelet count but still
no differential at this point in time
and i remember when we first got this
analyzer and still brings a smile to my
face when i think about it
because only the laboratory manager and
her deputy at the time were allowed to
use this analyzer
okay during the day night shift was a
different matter but during the day
only they were allowed to use the
analyzer of course
north day soon more often we all managed
to get our hands on this
and boy did you have to keep your wits
about you when you were doing this
if you could imagine your rack was
mixing the samples in your right hand
side
on the left hand side was your printer
where you put in your report cards for
printing the results out
you take the sample off the mixer take
the cap off introduce it to the analyzer
let it take another quarter of the blood
you then make your blood film
cap on put that into the sample rack and
then you would repeat that process
remembering to take out the results that
are printed out and put another report
card in for
the next set of results so
you felt like an octopus at times just
waving your hands about
manically but of course you also have to
keep your wits about you because you to
remember the sample number that you had
in your hand
was always two more than the counter on
the analyzer itself
so if you are distracted yeah
one or two mistakes were probably made
at that time and of course you would
then be looking for a set of results and
the report card wasn't there because
you'd forgot to put a report card
in the printer yeah it was carnage when
you kind of looked back at it
but we survived yeah and then
in late 80s we then got the inclusion of
a three-part differential
and that was neutrophils lymphocytes and
mononuclears
but of course the big change in the late
80s was the advent of the laboratory
computer of the limb system so no longer
manual transcription of results
we then moved to the mid-90s and we had
another analyzer which then produced a
five-part differential
the differential that we all know and
love to this day of course
and i love the unique selling point of
these analyzers when i was looking back
because it was designed for walk-away
automation
and it did exactly that i mean it was
quite revolutionary for the departments
at the time
in that you had a rack that would take
10 samples you would load that rack on
one side of the analyzer
it would take the iraq through analyze
all 10 samples
and inject the rack on the other side so
you'd have input
side and an output side and of course
you could load up to 10 racks
on the input side so that was 100
samples that you could place on an
analyzer
and actually walk away from so yeah it's
quite a big step there
we then took the leap into a fully
automated track
in 2008 and you can see from the picture
there what put it
the layout of the track and what we had
at the front there was a sample manager
and on the sample manager you could load
100 samples in that tray and the input
lay in there we had
two trays so that's 200 samples you
could actually load on the analyzer or
on the sample manager
it said any one time robots would then
pick up the samples from that trace and
deliver it
to the automated track it would then
deliver those samples to the appropriate
module
or analyzer and connected to the track
we had four full block analyzers we had
two
automated slide maker stainers we then
had a centrifuge unit for spinning down
our serum samples
and then we had an amino acid analyzer
for doing our b12s folates and ferritins
once the samples were completed they
would come back into the sample marriage
and sorry back into the sample manager
to be stored
or if a further test was required for
example
if there was a viscosity or an im slight
test or a malarial parasite for example
it would go to a dedicated area in that
sample manager
so a member of staff could come along
pick out those samples for ims or
samples from malaria no longer have to
search
through a trade trying to find the
appropriate sample
and also this could all be directed from
the individual sitting in front of the
track there
looking at the results and they decided
that maybe for example
we missed a blood film and wanted to
order a blood fill by ordering our blood
film against that sample number
the sample manager would then find that
sample put it back on the track
and it would be directed to the slide
maker stainer to make that that film
so again with a lot of ability to reflex
and made things a lot more manageable
and we eliminated a lot of manual steps
at that point of time by introducing the
the automated track
and before we jump to 2020 and where we
are currently
and i'll come back in with the
biochemistry
obviously my experience in the lab is a
lot shorter than paul's because i am
quite a lot younger than him
but from my experience of working in
biochemistry over the last 20 years
when i first started in the department
the lab was spread over lots of small
rooms
with specialist areas so we had a
chemistry area an amino acid area
we had toxicology areas in the order to
facilitate the implementation of the
automation
which in our lab looked very similar to
the picture on paul's slide there
and a lot of walls had to come down and
a lot of space had to be made
so our first generation track was
introduced slightly earlier than 2008
but was of a very similar description as
to who paul has given
we had a sample two sample monitors and
we have three chemistry analyzers
online centrifugation two amino acid
analyzers
and similar to what paul is describing
as well you can
configure your sample monitor to put
samples into angularjs that made
them easy to find or easy to pass on to
the next stage in the process
moving on to where we are now and
building on to that experience we're
actually
just have installed our third
incarnation of an automated track
our new systems build on what has
already been possible in terms of
online centrifugation decoupling and we
now have more advanced modules such as
there's a cop recognition module that
will look at the sample that's been
received and decided the
top is the right color for the type of
blood sample that is required for the
aussies that have been requested
now this is a massive bonus for us
because quite often
at the gp start to the end if a mistake
has been made and labeling up
a sample we might not always have
detected it at our
specimen reception bearing in mind the
amount of workload that we were handling
at any one time
so further progress that has been made
on the new automation things that are
new to us in this last year with our new
incarnation of automation
is looking more at the host analytical
so samples going back to cold storage
units online called storage units
so really touch time for the sample is
minimal
the samples are loaded on every step is
taken care of by the automation
i described already how we send referral
samples to referral labs
so the new generation of our automation
has got modules that allow alloquotes to
be made
online so this the alicorta unit will
generate a daughter chief it will
produce a label and so it will label
the daughter tube and the olive will be
placed in it so then all the member of
staff needs to do is
access that sample take it away and send
it on to the next lab
there's so much time saved by removing
repetitive manual tasks
and that is what the automation does for
you it also lets us have staff
as we mentioned at the beginning of the
presentation both haematology and
biochemistry
have low and working members of staff
who work overnight they are able to
criticize far more
inpatient samples that come during an
evening during the night shift
than if they had to do everything
manually and as paul is described as
they decide there's
a rerun to be done or an issue with an
instrument they can
schedule all of that from one location
rather than having to move around
getting samples and hunting things down
another added benefit
is that because we know the automation
will will robustly process
a certain number of samples within a
certain time we can't predict our
turnaround times more
accurately so if a gp wants to know if
his blood sample that he sent in on a
monday afternoon will be ready by a
tuesday morning
we can give him an honest answer to that
question that yes it probably will be
so let's go back to that previous slide
again just to build on that as well from
a hematology perspective and we've tried
to eliminate some of the steps that
we were still having to do even with our
previous automated track
and that was mainly looking at the pre
and post analytical
so we've introduced a recap around to
the track we've introduced
a d capper on the track as well so for
all those hematitic samples that we're
having to
to recap and people complaining about
their thumbs and having to stick all
these caps on
that's no longer an issue and we also
make the decision to
track our coagulation analyzers as well
so
you'll see there's a lady in the
distance there and suitably face mast as
well she would say
in that area and this picture was taken
about three months ago now
but just in the last six weeks we've
introduced our two
coagulation analyzers into that area as
well so samples no longer have to be
spun
offline they can be spun on the track
although we do still
spin the specialist coagulation offline
so again
just eliminating a lot of manual steps
there
one other things again because this is
fairly new to us as you can see i mean
we only started
going live on what was that three weeks
ago in hematology with the automated
track
not long before that for biochemistry so
this is very new automation to ourselves
as well
and we're still to build on this
automation another thing that we'll be
bringing in
hopefully end of this year beginning of
next year will be a refrigerated storage
module
so those samples will automatically go
from the track into the storage module
again these can be recalled if we wanted
to reflect samples
but they the added advantage there is we
can set time lights
so for example after two days we can say
that all the edta samples for full blood
cams
can be removed so they will
automatically be removed
into a multi-cloud bag ready for the
support worker just to pick up
and dispose of so no longer are we
having to go into fridges
empty rack after a rack of samples into
the autoclave
the automation will now deliver that for
us
we also will intend to have well we do
have two monitors
in each of the laboratories as well one
monitor will show you
the track and the and how things are
behaving how the analyzers are behaving
etc
so you can see that it's quite visible
from anywhere within the laboratory
the other monitor will show us our
turnaround times and we'll highlight if
they
were in danger of breaching at the
turnaround time for a
e or for amir also with the tracker we
have we now have priority lanes so we
can actually prioritize
our e a under the old system we were
unable to do that
but we can't truly prioritize our any
samples now
so just
so what we've done is we've fully
automated the the technical process
we've automated the pre-analytical and
we've managed to automate the
post-analytical process as well
but we still felt in hematology and
biochemistry there was an area that we
could improve upon
and that was when samples were being
delivered to the laboratory
so basically our sample reception area
up until about six months ago each
sample that was
that was delivered to the laboratories
came in an individual plastic sample bag
that bag had to be opened up we would
then scan the barcode label that was on
the sample
that would bring up the patient
demographics we would check that
against the properties being shown on
the computer and at that point we would
then
relabel the sample so we'd have a unique
laboratory identifier barcode label
and we would put that in the sample that
would then have to be scanned
and then we'd order the tests so you can
see a lot of manual
repetitive steps involved there in
booking in
samples we had discussed run through
labeling for a number of years
but because the limitations of our lymph
system were unable to take that step
but due to the perseverance of our
laboratory i.t colleagues in conjunction
with our limbs provider
we finally managed to crack that so what
happens now is
we can we introduce this just in primary
care in the first instance so we haven't
moved on to secondary care yet this is
just for primary care and gps
so by using the label that is produced
in the gp surgery
when that comes into the laboratory now
we can scan that label
we don't have to re-label the sample
anymore so against the
run-through labeling so you can see
we've already managed to eliminate a
couple of steps there
and all you think well it's a couple of
steps that's not gonna make a huge
amount of difference
when you think that's a couple of steps
on a thousand samples
that's a considerable amount of time
that we are actually saving and being
able to utilize that stuff better
but by moving to run through labeling
that then led us on to a significant
improvement
that would benefit not just the
laboratories but also the users of the
service for the gp surgeries themselves
so you can see in front of you there we
have a system and there's
four cradles there and in the far cradle
you see there's a rack
that will contain samples red insert
behind that rack
there's a black sensor and next to the
rack
there's a pc in monitor which is linked
into our lymph system
so we made a decision in july july this
year
that we invited 12 gp practices or gp
surgeries
to be involved in a pilot site these
were selected quite carefully because it
was the
the biggest numbers that were coming in
from those practices
so the big hitters as we called them so
we invited them to participate in the
pilot study and they were all extremely
keen to be involved in this
so what we did is we delivered two of
the cradles
units there numerous racks and one of
those black
sensor units to each practice
the reason we had to give them two of
these cradles
was we still needed to split out the
hematology samples from the biochemistry
samples
and that these were couriered in and
then delivered to the appropriate
department
as we said we're in different floors so
we don't have a common sample reception
at the moment
so we needed to be able to separate that
so of course we went very he says well
smile on his face we went very high tech
on this so you can see the rackets on
the cradle there has a red insert
red means hematology for the
biochemistry samples we introduced a
green insert
so from the gp surgery it was quite
simple red hematology
green was biochemistry so
if we go back to the gp surgery all they
then have to do is when you take that
sample
they would pass it in front of that
black sensor unit
and place it in the rack which is
sitting in the cradle
so with appropriate rack be the
hematology of the biochemistry one
when that sample is placed in the rack
it automatically
flashes or lights up that sample
position
and what it's doing there is it's making
an association with that
sample and patient demographics to that
particular position
on that rfid rack okay so this is the
important point there each one of those
racks can take up to 60 samples
so there's the big saving in itself
there for the gp practice
that's 60 less plastic sample bags
that is going into that rack no longer
required so
eliminating plastic waste and
interestingly before we started to
deliver this we were beginning to see a
lot more phone calls coming into the
department saying
do we really have to put a separate bag
separate sample into a separate bag
everybody being conscious of the the
climate of course
so that was why we were so keen to buy
into this process the fact that we were
eliminated eliminating plastic waste and
you can see from
the gp surgery we weren't asking to do
any more than what they were doing
instead of placing a sample in our bag
they were simply passing it in front of
the sensor
and placing it in the rack then you
could see the advantages
because of that waste of plastic and
eliminating plastic waste
our couriers will then come along pick
up those racks
and deliver them to appropriate
department so they would come into the
hematology and you can see
data we have here in that we have four
cradles that could be
scaled up it could be scaled down
depending on the on the workload
but we have four cradles here so when
the samples are delivered
we can place four four rats into these
cradles
we then go to the the pc and we would in
effect
accept those samples in and within
seconds
every single sample is within those rack
is booked into our limb system
so you can see how this is quite
groundbreaking for us in that we have
eliminated so many manual steps at some
perception
from these samples are being delivered
in this particular way
as we said we introduced this to 12
pilot sites in july
we then rolled that out to another 24
sites
in august again those that were sending
in the most samples
we felt there was no point in sending a
sample to gp surgery
and there are some of them who are
sending in maybe two samples a day
we didn't think it required it but we
still have some racks that we can put
out if we decide to
increase the number still so that's now
36 practices
into the 92 that have this system in
place
and although that's only 40 of the
practices at still
over 60 percent of the workload that's
now coming into the department
is now boot in in this way
and if we look at this graph here this
just highlights just how many samples
are coming in from primary care
in hematology in biochemistry so you can
see fifteen hundred
averaging fifteen hundred for hematology
about two two and a half thousand for
biochemistry but even allowing for sixty
percent of that coming in in this
fashion you're saying that's about 900
hematology samples
and about 13 1400 biochemistry samples
that are coming in this way
so that's over 2 000 sample bags that
we're not having to use anymore
so there's a shoe saving in waste and
also a financial saving to the
organization as well
in disposing of that plastic waste but
also that's also 2 000
samples that are being booked in within
seconds of coming into the department
so you can see what a huge difference
that has made
and we're very slick now when it comes
to the sample reception area
with regards to the run through labeling
you can also see there that 99.2
of samples are now received with a label
so
even though they're not in this system
we still have that not having to
re-label that sample
so again a huge bonus for the laboratory
yeah just to continue on from what paul
said there and
the implementation of pre-analytical
automation
gives additional benefits for
biochemistry as well
once the systems are fully implemented
as paul indicated we're still in the
early pilot stages of getting this
implemented
but we will have the facility where we
can predict we can have a look in the
system
to see what's being booked in the gp end
so that we can
confidently know what kind of workload
is coming into the lab that evening
so we can decide maybe we want to have
another instrument a chemistry analyzer
ready to go
word of more stuff available or if some
economy here because they're off sick
do we need to replace that member of
stuff actually know the workload tonight
is quite light so we'll be okay
so there's massive advantage advantages
for us as well
so just to conclude and if i can just
come in one second there's
one thing i didn't forget to add there
was we also have the facility
when we put it into that cradle to
create work lists as well
because immunology is on the same floor
as hematology they come in in the same
rack
so how to identify which samples are
hematology and which samples are
immunology
so by creating an immunology work list
we would simply click on that work list
and every sample that was designed to go
to immunology
would flash so we would quite easily
just highlight those samples pick those
samples that were flashing
and they would set them aside for
immunology or
if we wanted to set up a workplace for
say malarial parasites or im slide tests
again by simply clicking on that work
list if we wanted to prioritize
those it would flash on those samples of
labor parasites so again
we could pick those samples out and
prioritize them so again
it's just improving the efficiencies
within the department
sorry definitely and i think
as you compare through our presentation
that is the main conclusion that we
would come to
we're able to manage ever increasing
work clues
with our automation because we have just
upgraded our automation this year we've
got built-in flexibility now for the
next 10 years
and assuming our numbers keep on going
the way they have been we'll be able to
cope with our workload with the staff
that we've got
we can improve our our turnaround times
because we can't predict what's going on
we can see when samples are going as
well described using our dashboards we
can see if a sample is going to reach
return around time
so that's improving our quality and
decreasing error rates
things like cop recognition help us so
much and
that was quite a common error that we
had in biochemistry before
was that a glucose tube would be labeled
wrongly and analyzed on a gold top
sample
we wouldn't always pick that up at
specimen reception so using the
automation cleverly is a letting that
happen
and so therefore we're maximizing our
efficiency and this allows us to utilize
our skilled staff to do the skilled
tasks that they have been trained to do
thank you and ann and paul for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
now let's get started our first question
is
which quality guidelines do you have to
follow and how is automation helping
with them
okay i'll take this one paul um that's
in nhs grampian are all um accredited by
ucas which is the uk accreditation
service
we are accredited against isil 15189
standard
and that's the 2012 revision and
obviously the ucas accreditation process
follows every aspect of
our service from pre-analytical um
requirements to the ultimate the actual
rca
results we're producing and reports that
are going on
as we've described um using automation
just gives us
a far better um handle on what is
actually happening in the lab
and in terms of reducing errors in terms
of the pre-analytical sex that we've
described
wrong tube types for example samples
that are not appropriately barcoded will
be read by automation
but above and beyond that we can use the
automation to help us so much more with
quality
issues for example audit so using the
middleware we haven't really spoken very
much during the presentation
about the middleware that we use with
the automated systems that we have
so the current the middleware allows you
to do much more in terms of monitoring
so audit time for example how many
samples you're analyzing what workloads
are
you know how many how many uni samples
you're getting requested
and what your turnaround time is are you
achieving your target turnaround times
as well touched on
for a and e samples or emergency short
turnaround time samples
and also you can use your middleware for
loads of other quality
applications such as looking at your iqc
trend analysis
um instrument to instrument comparison
which is a big thing
for the ucas accreditation and also we
haven't really touched very much on the
lab at georgia greece
but at dr greece hospital in elgin we
are on the same
um automation so we have the same
middleware so we can look at their cases
on their analyzers
and we can compare how they are
performing against the analyzers of
aberdeen
both for hematology and for clinical
biochemistry
this is important from a newcastle
interview as well if you have a patient
who's admitted to drugs and then
transferred to eri
you want to know that the results are
compatible so all through our assessment
visit visits the automation have
helped us achieve our accreditation
status
thank you anne and looks like we have
one more question here
you started very early with automation
in 2008
why did you decide to automate so early
any recommendation for someone who wants
to start automating now
i think that sounds like a question from
the answer i'll say that
in 2008 for you as you've finally said
so
so why did we go in 2008 i took over the
laboratory modules posts in hematology
in 2005
so we started the procurement process
the following year
for for the new analyzers that we wanted
to go to
and i always remember being the lone
voice at the time saying that we should
we should actually automate and i was
trying to make the point
it wasn't about just looking for what we
needed now
this was about trying to future proof
for the next 10 years
because quite often that procurement
process is for a 10 year
plus in this case it was 12 years before
we actually went to
our finally got analyzers back in again
so you do have to have that long-term
approach to what is required
one of my mantras of course as well was
making sure we got the right person to
do the right job
and an upskilling staff as well so
i didn't want to have biomedical
scientists breaking through racks trying
to find a sample
which happened in a daily basis because
somebody would come in and just put a
sample down
in the first space they could find in
iraq and inevitably that was the sample
you needed for a blood film or for a pb
for example so you'd spend hours trying
to find that sample
so that was wasn't efficient use of
staff time
so and again there was so much more it
was an increasing demand on staff time
so again this was all about getting the
right person doing the right job
so by automating a lot of that process
we had the biomedical support workers
actually
running the automated track we had them
doing the maintenance on the analyzers
as well
so that was freeing up the the dms staff
to do the technical side of things
the paperwork side of things that were
required for ucas etc
so it was all about that much of getting
the right person to do the right job
and an interesting story of course was
we had one member of staff who
was in a highlight like the cell then
i've tried like years shall we say
of looking forward to retirement and of
course that was the last thing she
wanted was an automated track coming
into
the department it did terrify her to a
degree
and again she didn't think it was
required which was
a bit of overkill there and i remember
two years later
at a retirement function are coming up
to me and saying
you were right you know that's the right
thing to do and for
for that to come from that individual it
was quite a
i kind of took it back i'd have to say
before for this individual to actually
come back and say that to me so again
you could see that we had the buy-in
from the staff
because they could see the benefits of
automating that process
so for md it's thinking me is it the
right thing to do for me or is it not
just have a look around you at me how
much what how much
manual tasks are repetitive tasks are
you actually having to do
have you got the staff to actually
provide to do those
manual tasks or can you utilize your
staff better
and again it depends on the workload
it's coming in etc as well
but i would say i mean don't be afraid
of automation
we've certainly embraced automation
since since 2008
and we continue to embrace it as you can
see with the new system
with it it's sample reception the more
we can do to help self
and minimize the stress because all
staff are under stress these days
because of the increasing demands on
them so the more that we can automate
and allow them more free time to do the
things that are necessary
is a bonus as far as i'm concerned
and an additional recommendation to that
is just
to not be limited by what you know
automation makes anything possible
you know we're seeing this with our
latest generation of automation
things like putting third-party
analyzers onto your automated track
is now possible and you can use the
middleware for looking at qcs from
for analyzers that are not even on the
track anything is possible
so it is like your recommendation for
moving forward with automation
dream the love that you would always
want and see if you can build it with
automation
so don't be scared as paul said
that's a very good point that anne's
made there is i mean don't be
comfortable with what you know
i remember i mean i i felt i was being
quite visionary at the time thinking
we needed to go to an automated track
and we had a site visit to a hospital in
barcelona
which kind of blew all our minds and
just what they were providing on a fully
automated track
so from my vision of maybe having a
little weird
dinky track it kind of moved on so much
i always say
because i i've got that opportunity to
do it so again
if you are coming to procurement get
your
get your providers to take you to areas
that would be of interest to you
expand your your knowledge it might not
be right for you but at least see what's
available out there
it might grow a seed in you so
i wish listen yeah get your wish list
well thank you anne and paul do you have
any final comments for our audience
just thank you for for watching and i
hope you've enjoyed the presentation
yeah and don't be afraid of automation
it works for us
yeah well thank you again ann and paul
for your time today
and for your important research we would
also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor abbott diagnostics for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speakers
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye